How do you use the results in the new
personality test for progress in life?
Try to compensate some sides
that that received fewer points.
Well,
at the risk of sounding self serving,
that's actually why we developed the
self authoring suite was to help people
improve their,
let's say performance and mental health.
Now we don't have direct
evidence that will,
that will improve personality,
but I suspect that that evidence would
take a very long time to accumulate.
What we do know is that
the self authoring suite,
especially the future authoring suite,
um,
helps people,
helps university students,
for example,
stay enrolled in university.
It increases the probability of that
by about 25% and increases grade point
average by about the same.
And there's good theoretical reasons for
assuming that writing is a good way of,
of um,
as writing about yourself and about your
past and about your future is a good
way of catalyzing personality
transformation because it appears that
personality,
the human psyche is organized at
the highest level of abstraction.
Using something like self narrative and
a well developed narrative makes a frame
for your life and,
and helps you stabilize your negative
emotions and also experience more positive
emotion because you only
experience positive emotion
and relationship to a goal.
And that can make goal directed
activity lot more rewarding.
So,
you know,
it's a lot easier to engage in activities
that aren't intrinsically rewarding if
they're linked to something
that you really find important.
And so I would say if you want
to work on your personality,
well the first thing you have to do is
figure out who it is that you want to be.
And then you have to make a plan and
maybe you have to clean up your past as
well.
And the self authoring suite was designed,
you know,
quite carefully in order to help people
do that with a relative minimum of
effort.
Not that it's easy because it's not,
but a relative minimum minimum of
effort compared to other technologies,
let's say,
and like,
like longterm psychotherapy and,
uh,
to make it cost effective as well.
So.